our subject for tonight is
obedience has side effects
if we will but listen god's created works will
teach us precious lessons of obedience and trust
from the stars that in the trackless courses
through space follow from age to age their
appointed path down to the minutest atom
the things of nature obey the creator's will
and god cares for everything and
sustains everything that he has created
he who upholds the unnumbered worlds throughout
immensity at the same time cares for the wants
of the little brown sparrow that
sings its humble song without fear
when men go forth to their daily toil as when
they engage in prayer when they lie down at night
and when they rise in the morning when the rich
man feasts in his palace or when the poor man
gathers his children about the scanty board
all are tenderly watched by the heavenly father
no tears are shed that god does not notice
there is no smile that he does not mark
steps to christ page 85 paragraph four god is
good come on say it with more life than that god
is good and all the time i am privileged to be
with you i say that with concentrated sincerity
last night's mistake was entirely my fault i
did not read clearly what the pastor sent me
so please lay the blame at my footsteps not at the
pastors he's 100 innocent and i the other sign of
that coin i am 100 percent guilty but you look
like nice people and so perhaps you'll forgive
me before i'm finished speaking tonight thank you
for that for the two or three of you who said yes
we have is there anyone present who is not
a seventh-day adventist to meet your help
anyone all right i'm always honored by having
guests perhaps at a missouri city or born again
we have some guests if that's the case and you're
tuned in thank you very much and may the lord
bless your life in every possible way again i'm
grateful to god for the honor of standing in this
sacred desk to speak for him and i thank your
pastor pastor bob for extending this blessed
invitation to me i read in elohim's writing
somewhere that angels occasionally ask god to let
them speak and he tells them no let sinners such
as i do the speaking so i'm aware that i'm doing
something angels right now would love to do and as
a mark of gratitude to god i will simply give you
thus saith the lord can you say amen and perhaps
some insight from his servant ellen white
before i get into the message there's someone i
want to pray for with the passover adele jermaine
the little one is sick and we want to just annoy
little adele you know jesus christ was her age
he really was he was five and so i believe god
has a special affection in his heart for little
children because they're so innocent and so
helpless and so we'll pray for adele she's
here to receive some treatment and we'll ask god
to be gracious and merciful to her for his glory
in the lives of those who find out what he has
done for adele how old is adele she is five years
old as i said earlier jesus was exactly that size
and exactly that age hard to believe but yes god
who said let there be light came to this earth
and was exactly her age so i'll simply anoint
adele with the oil there's no healing virtue
in the oil we're simply obeying the word of god
james chapter 5 from verse 14 is any sick among
you let him call for the elders of the church
and let them pray over him anointing him with
oil in the name of the lord and the prayer of
faith shall save the sick and this is what we'll
ask god to do elohim says in desire of 80 speech
8 23 paragraph 4 christ is just as willing to
heal today as when he was personally on the earth
but there's something called obedience that
goes along with healing and we'll put much of
that burden on the mother uh to live that
kind of life so that the child grows up
in an atmosphere where god is obeyed because
obedience is a foundation stone of healing
physical and spiritual by the way our subject
for tonight is obedience has side effects
and so i can't wait to get into that for you
right now we'll kneel but before we kneel i'll
annoy
if it does not cause you physical
distress please kneel with us
our father in heaven we thank you today god
for the honor the privilege we have to come
before you in the name of jesus and to call you
father we thank you lord for your stubborn love
your long-suffering nature
your patience your mercy
as we bow before you they god if we sin against
you forgive us because sin is the source of all
our problems cleanse us dear god in the blood of
your son because that's why he came we're kneeling
to god to present to you little adele tremaine
jermaine who is not well in a very serious way
father your son jesus was her age he was a healthy
boy but he was your age you understand little
children father i believe you have a special love
for them that's why jesus said suffer the little
children to come unto me and forbid them not and
in obedience to that we have brought adele to you
their god in the name of jesus father have mercy
on this little girl let the treatment be effective
and father you step and go beyond the treatment
and pour out divine healing upon this little girl
that her life may be a life from henceforth
where she glorifies your name by constantly
talking of your goodness in her life touch the
minds of the doctors providing the treatment
that all the decisions may be right let the
angels guide their hands that all physical
manipulations may be right father do something
the reckless in the life of adele i pray from
my heart and i believe we all agree so father
we place this little girl in your loving hands
touch her physically touch her spiritually let
your spirit reside in the little heart i pray let
the angels protect her grant her that healing day
god i offer this prayer for my heart in jesus name
amen all right god bless you
adele okay you're welcome
god is good and all the time how many of
you love god nice your hands you love god
when was the last time you told him ah all
right tell him often often tell god father
i love you he'll appreciate that i'm quite sure
god loves to be told that i love you but back it
up with an obedient life can you say amen because
he tells us in john 14 15 if you love me keep
my commandments before i get into the message
do three little favors for me favor number one
preserve reference where you are monitor your
children those of you watching online i say the
same to you with great respect but directness
preserve reverence where you are as i always
say or frequently say the fact that some of this
program is online does not reduce the holiness
of god god is holy whether he's on zoom youtube or
whatever else we may be using facebook he is still
god favor number two while i'm
speaking pray for me and say lord
put your words in that man's mouth jeremiah
chapter 1 verse 9 says then the lord put
forth his hand and touched my mouth think of
that his hand divine touched my mouth human
and the lord said behold i have put my words in
thy mouth the bible says we have this treasure in
earth and vessels and i want to speak only god's
words prophets in kings page 6 26 the words of the
bible and the bible alone should be heard from the
pulpit favor number three the hardest of all think
think isaiah 1 18 come now let us reason together
saith the lord we serve a reasoning god we serve
a reasonable god and he tells us come now let
us reason together let's borrow heads and pray
father in heaven we thank you for life despite
all the trials and tribulations we're grateful
to be alive if we sinned forgive us we ask you
earnestly for an outpouring of your holy spirit
he is the spirit of truth and jesus tells us in
john 16 13 albeit when he the spirit of truth
is come he will guide you into all truth grant me
that spirit there god that the words i speak may
be your words possess my mind possess my mouth my
tongue every part of me associated with speech and
thinking directed bless everyone listening bless
all those online and father if anyone under the
sound of my voice has contracted the coronavirus
in the name of jesus the great physician heal that
person that god because you are a god of mercy and
a god of love do that i pray father for your glory
and that we may have a testimony to give now
father speak through me very directly i pray
in jesus name let god's people say amen and amen
this side what's our subject too slow that side
yes obedience has god's people ought to be
quick and sharp obedience has side effects
genesis chapter one do you have it ah god bless
you for being quick you are severely adventist
genesis chapter one we'll read from verse one
in the beginning god created the heaven and
the earth that's my favorite bible verse in
the beginning god created not evolution the
heaven and the earth now we know god took
six days to create and he rested on the
seventh on the first day god made light
on the second day the firmament the third day
separated water from dry land and made vegetation
on the fourth day sun moon and stars on the fifth
day sea creatures birds of the air on the sixth
day land animals and human beings as god looked at
the six days of work here's what god said verse 31
of genesis 1 and god saw everything that he had
made and behold it was very good keep your mind on
behold it was very good god placed adam
and eve in an environment that was by god's
description and no one can assess more accurately
than god the environment was very good the animal
life the plant life the atmosphere the social
arrangement god initiated between adam and eve
called marriage everything the fact they had to
rest one day of the week all of that was very good
genesis chapter 2 16 17. our subject obedience
has side effects by the way those side effects are
blessings you have genesis 2 verse 16 the bible
says and the lord god commanded the man saying
no i'll put this in my own words if you desire
to remain in a perfect environment no sickness
no misery no plagues no pandemics
no divorce no disobedient children
no wars no plagues no flooded cities if you desire
to remain in such an environment forever obey me
now let's read how it's actually written
and the lord god commanded the man saying
of every tree of the garden thou may freely
eat but of the tree of the knowledge of good
and evil thou shalt not eat of it for in the
day thou eatest thereof thou shall surely die
this is a passage which i refer to over
and over when i preach because the gospel
is very very simple the bible says of god in
second peter chapter 3 verse 9 the lord is not
slack concerning his promise as some men count
slackness but is long suffering to us word not
willing that any should perish let's commit
that let's add that to first speed first timothy
chapter two verse four who will have all men to be
saved and to come unto the knowledge of the truth
that's how you acquire knowledge with the
head directed by the spirit of god now
god's desire is that all people will
come to a knowledge of the truth
all people are not highly educated yet god
wants all people to come to a knowledge of
the truth which means the truth must be simple
are you with me all right let me pray again
father in heaven continue to be
with me suppress my carnal nature
that your glory may be my only object in jesus
name i pray amen yes what are you saying sister
oh you caught it all right all people yes educated
uneducated rich poor white black green pilgrimage
right god wants everyone to understand the truth
of the gospel the gospel therefore must be simple
in the light of the simplicity of the gospel i
ask you this question what's the problem god had
give me one answer starts with an s ends with an n
sin sin what's the only problem we have
sin why did jesus christ come to die sin
he did not come to die because
women couldn't find husbands
someone did not have a phd
lack of education is not a sin a single life
is not a sin christ didn't die to make everyone
rich monetarily because he himself was poor
jesus christ came and died because of sin
if that's clear say amen now listen again to
genesis 2 16 17 and the lord god commanded
the man saying of every tree of the garden thou
may freely eat notice the key word command and
i spoke about that last night commanded we have
it again in genesis chapter 2 verse 3 11 and 3 17
where god says commanded commanded commander of
every tree of the garden thou mayest freely eat
but of the tree of the knowledge of good and evil
thou shalt not eat in other words don't do that
do not eat of the tree we know thou
shalt not kill we know thou shalt not
commit adultery we know thou shalt not steal
initially thou shalt not eat of that tree
he did i am dealing with the
simplicity of the gospel he did
genesis 3 verse 17 says and the lord and unto adam
he said because thou has hearkened unto the voice
of thy wife and has eaten of the tree of which
i commanded thee saying thou shalt not eat of it
curse is the ground for thy sake in other words
god is saying because you disobeyed now go to
romans chapter 5. quickly romans 5 you read verse
19 i read from the king james version of the bible
romans 5 i'm matthew mark luke john x romans
if you have it go to chapter 5 and read verse
19. if you have my version read with me have you
found it yet read with me what does that force say
for as by one man's disobedience come on many
were made go on so by the obedience of one
shall many be made righteous stop now think think
who is that one man's disobedience adam who's the
one man's obedience jesus christ the second
adam so then the problem arose because of what
disobedience the solution
is obedience through christ
read verse 19 again for as by one man's
disobedience many were made sinners
so by the obedience of one shall many be made
right what i'm trying to get into your mind is
this you cannot remove obedience from the
gospel i don't see a clock oh there it is
i thank you what was my last statement
you cannot do what remove obedience
now a lot of christians would
love to remove obedience
in order to let me live any life i choose and then
save me let me tell you something about the gospel
go to first peter chapter 4. our subject obedience
has side effects every one of them is a blessing
what book did i say what chapter what verse 17.
thank you for being alert do you have it
two people have it anybody else has
it read with me for the time has come
that judgment must begin at the house of
god keep reading and if it first begin at us
what shall the end be of that obey not the gospel
now the gospel therefore must be what obeyed
for those who like to hide behind charge
of uh legalism no the gospel must be obeyed
but we're not one text christians
let's go to second thessalonians
chapter one ii thessalonians chapter one
our subject obedience has side effects
and they're all blessings what book did i say
what chapter reading verses seven and eight
do you have that who can recite all 66 books
in order can i see your hand you can you raise
your hand with degree of uncertainty my brother
all right you were more confident i believe you
all right okay i won't call you up tonight second
thessalonians one reading verses seven and eight
and to you who are troubled rest with us when the
lord jesus shall be revealed from heaven with his
mighty angels now read it with me in flaming fire
come on taking vengeance on them that know not
god and that obey not the gospel of that's right
so here again we have the gospel must be obeyed
but there's something else the gospel that must
be done to the gospel let us go to uh mark chapter
1 read verses 14 and 15 our subject obedience
has side effects it's 26 minutes to uh eight
do you have mark the shortest gospel mark was
not one of the twelve disciples neither was luke
read with me now after that john was put in prison
mark chapter 1 from verse 14 sorry i'm not sure if
i told you jesus came into galilee preaching
the gospel of the kingdom of god verse 15 and
saying the time is fulfilled come on the kingdom
of is at hand go on repent believe the gospel
wait a minute what did we learn earlier we must do
what obey the gospel what is john the baptist said
what did jesus say believe the gospel is there
conflict no because where there is belief there
is obedience the only proof that you truly believe
or have faith jesus said believe the gospel
and his spirit inspired peter and paul
to write obey the gospel go to galatians
galatians chapter 2
we read verse five
paul is talking about his uh visit to uh jerusalem
which is also recorded in acts chapter 15.
and he runs into some jews who are trying to get
new converts to go back to the old jewish ways
and keep all the little ceremonial laws
verse 5 of galatians 2 let me pray again
father in heaven continue to be with me i appeal
to you in jesus name amen read with me to whom
we give place by subjection know not for an hour
that the truth of the gospel might continue with
you now keep in mind he says the truth of the
gospel i want you to think let's go to verse 14.
read with me but when i saw
that they walked not uprightly
according to the truth of the gospel so we
have truth of the gospel in verse five we have
truth of the gospel in verse 14. now let's be
reasonable god calls us to reason let's go to
chapter three of the book of uh galatians
our subject obedience has side effects
chapter three verse one all foolish galatians
who have bewitched you now you read for me
that you should not obey the truth but that you
should not obey the truth finish it no no no no
no no no hold it hold it think with me think let
me give you some help chapter 2 verse 5 says the
truth of the gospel chapter 2 verse 14 says the
truth of the gospel now read verse 1 of chapter 3
let me see who's thinking come on read loudly oh
foolish galatians come on who have befitted you
oh no no no no stop stop
embarrassing heaven and earth
listen again you must think when setting the word
of god you must think listen again chapter 2 verse
5 we have the truth of the gospel chapter
2 verse 14 the truth of the gospel now read
verse 1 of chapter 3 again all foolish galatians
who hath bewitched you that you should not obey
the truth of the gospel
now we don't have it physically
written but based on chapter 2 verse 5
and chapter 2 verse 14 and because the
bible says let's reason together what he
means is who have bewitched you that you
should not obey the truth of the gospel
let's go to chapter five
read for seven of galatians
galatians five for seven do you have
that read with me he did he did unwell
who did hinder you come on that he should not
after ah i heard that god bless you god bless you
i give you an a for being adventist yes the truth
of the gospel what are you seeing obey obey obey
in the middle of the gospel is obey but let
me hammer it home because we hate obedience
philippians chapter two reading from verse
five our subject obedience has side effects
philippians chapter two reading from
verse five when you found it say amen
if you're still looking say amen that's
an honest man but get uh hurry up hurry up
philippians chapter two from verse five i think
he has it now let this mind be in you which was
also in christ jesus who being in the form of god
thought it not robbery to be equal with god but
made himself of no reputation took upon him the
form of a servant and was made in the likeness of
men and being found in fashion as a man he humbled
himself come on and became obedient unto death
even the death of the cross that even the
death means the depth of the obedience of
jesus he became obedient even it meant killing him
he will be not just any death if i had to choose
a way to die i would not choose being eaten by a
lion are you following me i would not choose being
burned alive i would choose a lethal injection
or laughing gas something pleasant and they'll
go to sleep and i'm gone all death is not the same
that's why the bible says and became obedient unto
death even in other words there was no limit
to the obedience of jesus christ to his father
because he lived that kind of
life listen to his testimony
john chapter 8 let's go to verse 29 our subject
obedience has side effects is a quarter to eight
god is good and all the time yes he
is he cannot be anything else but good
that's his habit what book did i
say what chapter 8 what verse 29
read nice and love for me and he that have sent me
is with me the father hath not left me alone why
for i do always those things that please
him now listen to this expression all
i do always those things that please
him give me one word for that obey
but there's a problem god requires
obedience of people who cannot obey
and i need to pray again father as i
enter into this section of the message
please god give me simple but powerful language
in jesus name i pray amen go to romans eight
romans eight three verse seven and verse eight
you have romans eight all right read with me
because the carnal mind is enmity against
god stop give me another word for enmity
against okay enmity give me
another strong word enmity
hatred hatred the carnal mind is
hatred it doesn't say it has hatred
it is hatred because the carnal
mind is enmity against god
why keep reading for it is not
subject to the law of god stop
give me one word for not subject to the law
of god it is it is disobedient by nature
now here's god requiring obedience from
people who because of sin are unable to obey
then god has to do something here is
what god has promised to do ezekiel 36.
in salvation god moves first somebody say amen
if he didn't move first we'd be in trouble
in salvation god moves first what book did i
say what chapter 1 verse 26 and 27 are you there
not yet some of you still
on your cell phone bibles
are you ready read with me a new heart also
will i give you stop why does
god have to give us a new hand
we can't do it for ourselves are you with me we
cannot now this promise is not first mentioned
in ezekiel listen to genesis 3 15 tell me
what that verse says without going there
and i will put enmity between the
other woman where's enmity put
now we have enmity twice we found enmity in romans
8 7. but this enmity is directed towards god
i've lost you i've lost you you might as well
confess it let me try again it's my fault
romans 8 7 says because the
carnal mind is enmity against god
here's what god promised to do very first
promise of the bible and i will put enmity
between thee and the woman god has promised to put
hatred in our hearts for the things of the devil
so when he tells us in ezekiel 36 26
and our new heart also will i give you
and the new spirit will i put within you and
i will take away the stony heart out of your
flesh and i will give you a heart
of flesh now read verse 27 for me
and i will put my spirit within you
come on and cause you to do a walk in my
statue stop what do you understand by cause
you to walk in my statutes i will make you obey
you said amen because you're nice people
but you didn't get it god has promised he
will make us obey
and so all we have to do is to say father do for
us what david told you to do for him in psalm 51
verse 10 what does that verse say creating me a
clean heart oh god you do that and renew all my
spirit within me why because i cannot do it i'll
tell you something else i do not want to do it
go to romans 3 what's our subject too
slow too slow obedience has side effects
yeah i like that vegetarian all right romans
chapter three reading from first time do you
have that read with me what does this say but
as it is written yes there's none righteous
come on no not one keep eating there's none
there's none that seeketh after god stop
the sinner does not naturally
say god god has to do something
so god has to change the heart god has to change
the mind god has to give it that spirit because we
do not desire it we have two problems we don't
want it even if we wanted it we couldn't do it
that's why in a certain sense it's all of god
and so god says a new heart also will i give you
then when i read that what should i say to god
father give me what that new heart a new
spirit will i put within you and i'll stop
practicing spousal abuse i'll stop lying
why because i'll have the spirit of jesus
i'll stop stealing the tithe i'll stop working
on sabbath why because i'll have the obedient
spirit of christ god has promised now i'll
tell you something about god god does not lie
no can't lie titus chapter 1 verse 2 which god
that cannot lie promise before the world began
numbers 23 19 god is not a man
that he shall lie meaning men lie
god said i will put in your heart in you i
will cause you that's what he did for christ
listen to what christ said in
john 14 go with me to john 14.
10 minutes to eight i'll finish at eight
have a long flight back to missouri city
it felt like a flight coming down that's
okay all right what book did i say john 14
let's read from verse 8. we read the words of
philip then the words of christ are you there
read with me philip saith unto him lord
show us the father and it sufficeth us
jesus said unto him have i been so long time
with you and yet hast thou not known me philip
he that have seen me have seen the father and
how says thou then show us the father keep
reading believers thou not that i am in the
father and the father in me the words that i
speak unto you i speak not of myself but the
father that dwelleth in me he did the work stop
it was the father working through jesus
as the father worked through jesus jesus must
work through us now listen to galatians 2 20 say
it without don't go there you say it without going
i am crucified with christ come on nevertheless i
live yet not i but christ liveth in me stop
it's not what christ said about the father
living in him then paul says who lives
in him jesus this is the only way
we can obey god and let me tell you quickly
for those of you who take pride in your
obedience obedience is not compliance inmates
comply ah you didn't hear me inmates comply
are you following that's not obedience listen
to obedience christ object lessons page 97
paragraph three the man who attempts to keep the
commandments of god from a sense of obligation
merely because he's required to do so will never
enter into the joy of obedience he does not obey
when the requirements of god are considered a
burden because they cut across human inclination
we may know that the life is not a christian life
true obedience is the outworking of a principle
within it springs from the love of righteousness
the love of the law of god the essence of all
righteousness is loyalty to our redeemer this
will lead us to right because it is right because
right doing is pleasing to god the obedience is
that which proceeds from a love of righteousness
obedience has side effects blessings blessings
for this life come on finish my words
and the life to come
christ came and died because of disobedience
because of his obedience we are restored our right
to the tree of life and so the last chapter of the
bible revelation 22 verse 14 don't go there say
it it's an adventist verse blessed are they that
do his command stop there is a blessing for those
who obey keep reading that they may have right to
the tree of life and may enter into the gate into
the city as we reason together we lost that right
through adam's disobedience we regained that right
to the obedience of christ working through us
my brothers and sisters we must come to the place
where our obedience is the obedience of christ
in the sense that as he became obedient unto
death we must be prepared to obey god unto death
like daniel yes that's why
god has to do through us
like the three hebrew boys like all the marchers
who went to the stick burned to death who went
to the cathedral not the cathedral the
amphitheater consumed by wild animals and
the stories tell us some when they were burning
they were singing hymns total commitment to god
many who profess to be christ followers have an
anxious troubled heart because they are afraid
to give themselves to him they
do not make a complete surrender
because they shrink from the consequences
that such a surrender may involve
unless they make this surrender they cannot have
peace minister of healing page 480 paragraph three
the surrender must be total because
god does not tolerate partial obedience
counsels for the church page 268 paragraph
five god the history of god's dealing
with his people in all ages shows that he
demands exact obedience that's not legalism
peter has some prophets page 479 paragraph two
god shut moses out of canaan to teach a lesson
which should never be forgotten
that he requires exact obedience
if neymar had only dipped 6.9 times you
would never have recovered from leprosy
god gave us 10 commandments those commandments are
a sign of his people in the last days he gave ten
not nine and for someone listening to me who's
observing sunday contrary to thus said the lord
make that change you've got one change to
make to come into full harmony with god
just one you love the other nine let your love
for the other nine lead you to obey the fourth
obedience has side effects and so i ask you five
minutes to eight i want you to think of what
i'm about to say is there an area in your life
where you know you're disobedient you willfully
deliberately intentionally flagrantly disobedient
shut it down tonight give it to god so father
i have been rebelling against you in this area
of my life please dear god i surrender it to you
grant me the obedient heart of jesus you promised
in ezekiel 36 26 a new heart also i give you give
it to me their god and remove this area of
rebellion and stubbornness ask god to do
that because it only takes one area of rebellion
to take you straight to hell when jesus said the
kingdom of heaven is like a grain of mustard
seed he could have said the kingdom of hell
is like a grain of mustard seed you take that
mustard seed of wrong and leave it unattended
it will grow and consume the life tonight i offer
you the only foundation of endless blessings
that foundation tell me what it is obedience
to god jesus died because someone disobeyed
we are able to enter the pearly gates
when christ comes because somebody obeyed
and because we have a nature that hates god's
law god does something divine in the life
he changes that person with the person's
permission a decent life is an admirable thing
christ did not die to make you decent you can do
be decent without christ's help christ didn't die
to make us well cultured and smooth and we can do
that without his help otherwise says many a man
of cultured intellect and pleasing manners who
would not stoop to what is commonly regarded as
an immoral act is but a polish instrument in the
hand of satan christ died to change our hearts
to make us like him and when we say the
lord's prayer say it with me our father
who art in heaven hallowed be thy name thy kingdom
come you go on how on how as it is in heaven
which means to your shock perhaps while on this
earth we're called by god to live a heavenly life
thy will be done on earth as it is in heaven
the angels obey that way psalm 103 verse 20 bless
the lord ye his angels that excel in strength
that do his commandments hearkening unto
the voice of his word the angels obey and
god gives that same standard to us because
for the universe for god's kingdom there is
one standard that's the standard of his law
which expresses the very character of god
my brothers and sisters choose obedience
it's the only way to express love for god
and satan knows that that's why we're told
in great controversy page 582 paragraph one
from the very beginning of the great controversy
in heaven it had been satan's purpose to overthrow
the law of god it was to accomplish this that he
entered upon his rebellion against the creator
and though he was cast out of heaven he has
continued the same warfare on the earth to
deceive man and thus lead them to transgress god's
law is the object which he has steadfastly pursued
and you and i know from prophecy the issue of
crisis in the last days will be the law of god
shall i live by god's law or a man made law
tonight i ask you the presence of a holy god
choose obedience that flows from love calvary is
the most dramatic expression of the obedience of
love let that soften your heart and mind
and let us say lord hear am i change me
make me yours how many will stay with me tonight
father renew a new spirit within me write your
law again on my heart could you raise your
hands stand up with me please write that
law again because the ink is fading with all
the daily struggles is fading write it again
as bad eyes closed father in heaven we thank you
for your word and the challenge it brings to us
but whatever you required a god you provide
the power forgive us father where we've
fallen short forgive us their god where we have
accused you of having set low standards for us
you have called us to obey because the foundation
of your kingdom is your law and the life of christ
is a living example of that law in action please
god keep your word in ezekiel 36 26 a new heart
also will i give you and the new spirit will
i put within you do that for us dear god
right where we stand and renew it every day as
we depart this building let angels escort every
vehicle every pair of watch over us tonight bring
us back tomorrow day god to hear your word again
and let the lies believe between them and
now be a witness of your goodness to us i
off this prayer for my heart in jesus name
let god's people say amen don't sit here